so
that moment for me was very indicative
though because i saw like the pause and
i've been in that position that you're
in because i'm a free-thinking person as
well i can say we'll get into politics a
little bit but i consider myself a
libertarian conservative but i don't
ally myself with politicians i'm not
here to be a cheerleader for a
politician and that becomes a very
unpopular position to be in when you
work for cable news in particular
because the expectation is well if we're
on team this everybody there needs to
align with that
so
at that point when you when you had
moments like that happening did you
sense that something might shift at all
no at that point um
i
i
and you could kind of see in my face i
was genuinely shocked that they still
didn't know right i really thought
everybody knew at that point i was like
well of course the vaccine doesn't stop
this where we have all the data now from
israel like this is so obvious i mean
they're discussing now a booster i mean
it was just
i wonder when the date of that was if it
coincides with me it was august like it
was the it was actually yeah it was like
august um
maybe fourth or ninth or 11th something
like that okay well let me tell you i
went on the view in november and i don't
know if you saw this but i went on and i
was shouted down as misinformation for
simply saying that if you get the
vaccine you can still spread code you
can still get it and i did a radar on
that it was right and it was like as if
i had said something crazy in the
meantime by that point the cdc had even
acknowledged that so it was absurd that
it would be labeled misinformation but
this doesn't surprise me at all so you
do you know interviews i'm sure this
happened more than
that just one time that's just the one
you highlighted right and then suddenly
you who have been covering fouchy in
large detail you get news that fouchy's
going to be coming on the show and i'm
sure you were very excited because this
is your opportunity to ask some real
questions so tell me what happens you
get the news on a sunday night that fact
is going to be on the show and how does
that play out yeah it was on a slack
channel so we slack a lot of our
information you know amongst the the
production staff and one of them had
mentioned so like is fauci confirmed
that's all i saw was like is fouchy
confirmed and somebody said yes
and then i was like wait a minute is
fauci going to be on the show tomorrow
um and everything went radio silent no
one said anything on the slack channel
from that point forward and then a few
hours later i get a phone call from the
producers and they were like well
so yeah um about fouchy so here's the
thing um you know we they asked who was
interviewing him of course they did yeah
which i
and then they said we said robbie and
bacha we didn't put your name in and
then they asked again and we said ravi
and bacha and they asked again and we
said robbie and bacha so they're very
concerned about who's
host who's interviewing fauci we told
them robbie and botcha
so and i was like no guys i mean it's
all or nothing i mean just don't do the
interview then if they're not going to
have me on there then don't do the
interview you're going to upset the
audience
massively i mean if you don't have me on
that interview the audience will know
they won't trust you ever again like
this will be like cnn i mean you'll just
the audience trust is everything they
will not trust you
so just don't do it then go back to his
team say i'm on it if they back out then
we we do a segment on that instead of
the interview without you we talk about
how he backed out that he was a coward
and he wasn't willing to face
all of america you know he's only gonna
face the ones that like him but not the
rest like that's what so that's what
we'll do and they said okay you know
okay and then um
i prepared for that interview and then
the next morning
right before i was supposed to go on
they
called me again and said sorry we're
going to have this really uncomfortable
conversation but we've decided that
we're not going to go back to the fouchy
team and tell them that you're on it
that instead we're just going to go
forward with the interview as scheduled
and i just said
you know
the audience will not trust you and then
everything i have told the audience over
the last year that the reason i'm
sitting here the reason i left
independent media to come and work on
the corporate side was that i was not
going to be censored held back or
limited in any way and you guys are
going to basically
crash everything i've been saying for
the last year
and ruin that and then how can i come
back because i've been saying i'm here
because i'm not being limited or
censored the minute you do that to me i
can no longer say that so i can no
longer be here you're putting me in this
horrible position that was two hours
before the interview i then for the next
two hours proceeded to message all of
them including the hosts them the
management i told everybody do not if
you do this you put my future at rising
at risk
like don't do it because i how can i
stay i can't i've been telling the
audience that you guys are trustworthy
this whole time and now you do this to
me
so
they did it anyway
i i knew they were recording the
interview and then i begged them then
just don't air it okay fine you did it
don't air it like the minute you guys
air it
there's no coming back for me i can't it
would ruin my reputation right
but uh they decided to air it anyway and
then i said then that's it you guys made
the decision i mean we're going to get
to that interview in a second because i
watched it of course it's a terrible
interview by the way that they did
without her i'm going to say it because
you know how i am i got to speak the
truth um why do you think they they
chose not to go back to fouchy and say
that you needed to be in the interview
they didn't want to lose the interview
with fauci is what my guess would be is
that they thought that having him on
would bring the show credibility to some
degree i don't know why they thought
that
um everybody on the show criticized
fauci
so it wasn't like i was the mean one i
mean everybody criticized i was harder
for sure in a lot of ways
certainly i'd covered coveted way more
than any of the other hosts so it was
for sure my like beat more than anybody
else's
and it's interesting to me that they
felt that it would bring them
and this is your opinion about obviously
how they were feeling that right bring
them credibility to have fouchy but
somehow wouldn't bring them credibility
to have someone on their ass vouchy
tough questions which is really what
they should be doing yeah of course
fauci asked a hundred times you know
fouchy doesn't do interviews with anyone
that's gonna challenge him we all know
that so it's unsurprising that he asked
who was going to be in the interview and
i think he got exactly what he wanted
when i saw the interview if you like the
short clip you can catch another one
here or you can catch the full episode
right here
[Music]